[Music]
my guest today is a great example of
self-made artists she started writing
lyrics in middle school and made her own
demos throughout college eventually
those demos racked up hundreds of
millions of views on the social media
platforms now well now she's a
multi-platinum selling artist and she
was nominated for two grammys this year
one for best new rapper and the other
for best rap song we're talking about
sweetie come on girl get out of here
get out here no that's right hello how
are you good to see you nice to see you
nice to see you first sit down huh you
got some good cheese well first of all i
didn't ask for this i did i never had
this
uh this is a request from you you you
ask for the cheese plate uh candles i
don't i don't do the candles that's you
too you feel like you needed to set the
you need to set the vibe and obvious to
your liking for you to come out here
it's all about the vibe you're proud of
yourself mm-hmm yeah you feel like you
did good yeah i did great okay this is
my psalm come on in here man what we got
today mr hart what do we have sweetie
well i have a couple of amazing
selections with a third selection that's
being chilled in the cellar okay for
yourself
i'm going to start you off with a
beautiful red wine from northern
california a blend of portuguese grape
varieties called teeth decal tita rory i
was going to ask you was a tincture cow
absolutely you nailed it
let me see that let me hit the tink the
cow absolutely look at that
now for miss sweetie while your riesling
is in the cellar coming to proper
temperature how much does she ask for
everything
we've got a little lamer from the coast
central coast of california for you
chardonnay but i do have riesling in
order i don't do i like it
you're a reasonable drinker um i like
red wine yeah i just didn't want it to
like dye my teeth ah i can always bring
a glass of water always thinking always
thinking well we're here to be
comfortable so if that was the case and
i would make sure that you're protected
i would get it in an edit so if you want
some red you can have some red just let
me know that's okay okay all right my
god thank you man thank you both
i don't know i think i was a random you
want some red get the red absolutely
glass of red just line them up over here
for please uh cheers this is to you
thank you so much
for coming on let's talk about you let's
talk about uh where you're from from
sacramento right from the bay and then i
moved to sacramento
from the bay uh born and raised uh big
family hella big my mom's side is big
and my dad's side is big okay
when you say your mom's side is big your
dad sounds like how many how many
siblings what are we talking about here
so my dad's side nine uncles and aunties
and on my mom's side seven aunties and
uncles all protective of you yes very
protective are you considered the baby
not the baby what do you consider so i
was the first grandchild on my mom's
side and i was the first girl grandchild
on my dad's side okay now gabrielle
union is your cousin correct
um are you and gab like close do people
know about this do they not know about
this people know they do know um i never
knew that well she was my dad's first
cousin so he grew up with her
i never knew that mm-hmm i mean gab are
very close i don't know why dad wouldn't
tell me that
i don't know i don't know either kind of
pisses me off
pisses me off um gab's success early on
in her career i mean is that something
that sparked you
your interest for entertainment at all
was it something where you saw the
things that she accomplished that she
achieved was there a will and want
because of that or was yours more of a
discovery later on it was a discovery
later on when i was younger i wanted to
be a hair stylist really yeah i was like
in elementary school doing all my home
girls hair so i thought that's what i
wanted to do well you can't say hair
stylist and i not address your hair now
um this is the first time i've seen you
in short here i've never seen your short
hair why was we didn't prompted to short
hair i feel like it's symbolic to where
i'm at just in my human life what does
that mean define it
well i feel like
in quarantine i had time to do a lot of
like self-reflection
i learned how to meditate
and through meditation
i've had access to my higher self
okay and
that gave me a whole new experience and
when i did that i wanted to start fresh
and i did my research and i heard where
i read that hair holds a lot of energy
so
it's essentially the metamorphosis of
sweetie and diamante caterpillar into
butterfly
um i don't want to skip around too much
but i can't i can't not piggyback off of
this uh when you say you're your higher
self right of course we're talking about
self-discovery so
within self-discovery what is that you
were unhappy with or not satisfied with
of the other self the other version of
you
so
through meditation i learned about
chakras okay and i learned that a lot of
my chakras were like damaged defined
chakras for those who do not know let's
act like i don't know what it is i don't
i do i just act like i do so i didn't
know what meditation was meditation is
concentration focus self-awareness okay
i didn't know that chakras are energy
points with throughout your body okay
you have seven you have your root your
sacral your solar
your heart your throat your third eye
and your crown
i don't have three eyes
i don't have to get
but you're saying you're suggesting that
people that are familiar with the chakra
they have three eyes
no just saying
okay all right so in this in this
discovery right uh let's get to the root
of why like you don't just turn that on
that doesn't just happen you don't wake
up one day and go oh my god meditation
is what i've been missing like there's a
reason for it what was the reason for
you going down this path why well i was
really stressed out um i have two great
mentors bob and rants and they taught me
about
so big bob is like
he specializes in branding
and rants is a part of the 1500 group
and they have a music academy down at
inglewood so
um i met them created a great
relationship and they would see me
stressed out a lot and they was like do
you meditate i'm like
i don't meditate i don't believe in that
and then they broke it down and i tried
it and it was such a um a 180 for me now
when you say like uh you are stressed is
this is this the business you know i
have a lot of conversations on here and
a lot of the conversations always go to
a place where
we
talk about how nobody prepares you for
the world that comes with success right
um you know you're not an overnight
success but you're not an old person
you're very much a young a young female
a young player in the game of
entertainment and finding success the
way that you did i mean it did come kind
of fast so is that where the bulk of the
stress came from
yeah i've been stressed out for like the
last three years yeah
and and you felt like you were dealing
with it you like the stress that you
felt like you were hiding or
you felt like you were just
the stress with just being a woman being
a woman in the spotlight you know it's
like very microscopic it's like what are
you doing with your life everybody's
micro managing like your moves making
comments opinions i wasn't used to that
um and also like just by running my own
business i have my own employees
managing different personalities
different boundaries um
and trying to keep the balance okay when
you when you say
when you say the world of right you're
like okay wow it's a lot it's a lot for
me like i'm dealing with the world of
comments to dealing with the the the
lens that people are now looking at me
through do you feel like you were
misunderstood at any point do you feel
like you were a false version of
yourself
and you were never your true self like
i'm just trying to get to the discovery
of why you ended up going down the road
no i've always been my true self however
i've controlled that narrative like
just not showing too much of like my
personal life my personality
um
but the world of just the internet
celebrity paparazzi
people invading until you're like your
intimate space
i wasn't ready for that too much for you
it was just a lot just people commenting
on everything that i did makeup
relationships songs and you know my
artistry and i'm really like
it's like sensitive i'm sensitive about
that did you ever reach a breaking point
where you were like this is enough
i
haven't reached a breaking point
hopefully
i
don't ever come to the place where i'm
like i don't want to do this anymore but
i've had
tons of mental breakdown what what is a
mental breakdown to you what does that
mean
is that is that you snapping is that you
throwing stuff is it a fit what is a
what's a mental breakdown in your world
so i have a high tolerance
for
stress for pain for just
turmoil okay um
so my my mental breakdown is like
i feel like my body overheats i feel
like
the inside of me is like rotten
if i don't sleep a lot
i feel dehydrated and i feel like
like i just
it's like a weird yell cry sounds like
anxiety it sounds like a high level of
anxiety
and you then finding this world of
meditation you felt like you're able to
control that or now you're able to
deal with that in a much better
light better way yeah because meditation
helps with balancing your energy
centering yourself
it allows you to like think thoroughly
and clear without any distractions
and it's been such a gift to me
well if we talk about the world of
growth and success i mean
the people around you play a major key
right they play a big big part in that
do you feel like you've been able to
stay true to the same circle or has that
circle changed as your success levels
have changed
honestly i had a really like traumatic
experience in middle school and ever
since then like my circle has always
been tight i still got the same best
friend i still like
know the same people who i grew up with
since high school like who are very
close to me that's impressive yeah so
what was your traumatic experience
it just happened
what just happened to your face just now
so this is what happened so we had like
a girl click right you know middle
school
and i got a boyfriend for the first time
okay like and i was just i felt hella
cute it was me and him he was doing our
thing and we had a girl group and
i noticed that some of my best friends
started getting jealous of me and would
just do like smart remarks here and
there
and then one day i don't know what
prompted them to do this i woke up to
hell of voicemails
of them saying that they were going to
jump me oh my god yes
by the way i don't think there's no
bigger fear
there's no bigger fear so i'm in the
fear of knowing you're going to get
jumped yeah so i take a bus to school
we all ride the bus together so i'm just
like oh my god what time is it going
what time
so i saw my grandma my grandma was like
tell them to come to the house you told
your grandma yeah she was like my best
friend okay yeah where's your grandma
about it she was like she was like tell
them to come to the house because if
they come to the house no charges can
you know oh my god grandma's about that
life
grandma's about their life it's just for
like safety so i tell them they don't
respond
and this is how me and my current best
friend became best friends so she was
like i am not going to let them jump you
i don't know what she said to them she
called them they stopped calling me and
monday morning we was on defense
watching them they was watching us and
they didn't do nothing on defense by the
way spoken like a true
girl from the bay we were on defense i'm
gonna need some more wine this
conversation is about to get good please
pour me up so wait a minute so i'm gonna
give you a funny story uh same thing
happened but not as smooth right i was
told that uh that i was gonna get jumped
one time and uh the difference between
your story and mine is they actually did
it they jumped me uh yeah i didn't even
i didn't even see it coming either i was
at the locker i was at my locker doing
my code and one guy said yeah kev what's
all that
and i was like you tell me and all i
know is they came from this side it was
a very good diversion tactic they pulled
they made me look this way it only
lasted for about 15 seconds i don't know
if they all got a hit or not but it
definitely happened it went down so my
way of dealing with it was acting like
it never happened
yeah that's what i did
i just acted like it never happened so
afterwards like everybody was just
staring at me i got up and i was just
asking people to pass me my stuff i was
like give me my shoe because my shoe
came off there's nothing worse than your
shoe coming off from the fight yeah
cause you gotta put that on in front of
everybody get let me pass that please
thank you uh give me that book no the
the the algebra book thank you please
excuse me where's my backpack i just
walked it off but i definitely relate to
the whole world of knowing you're going
to get jumped
uh so you're a great storyteller well
it's a truth that's why all right that's
something that's still it acts maybe i
need oh my god what if that was my
chakra what if my chakra made me
remember that was my third eye where was
my third eye
it's about safety i bet it is it wasn't
it wasn't then you got to activate it
ladies and gentlemen we got to take a
break when we come back oh my god we got
more sweetie on heart to heart
[Music]
you didn't go anywhere because i didn't
let you go for long this is still hard
to heart and i'm still sitting here with
sweetie now well let's get into it
you're affecting lives you got people
that really are listening to you they
really are following your every moves
once again we're talking about music so
your creativity is important how do you
create
what's your process like you know for
you to put music on a piece of paper
right is there a period of time when
that happens or is it random are you
allotting a certain amount of time when
you say on these days i work on this
specific thing or is it a feeling and
when you get that feeling you say i'm
wrong with this feeling i'm going to the
studio what's your process
um honestly up until now because i told
my label my management when i record my
album
i need to go to a house and i need to be
designated i don't want nobody bothering
me
and i want to create and that's all i
want to do do you change the house like
you did my set do you put like cheese
plates and candles like that around it's
gonna be a vibe yes it's vibe okay but
before that like
recording was very strenuous to me
because i would be recording in
different cities
um one time i did a calvin klein shoot
dance rehearsals and then had to turn in
a song
yeah it was like
i felt like
my creativity spirit was
was it nourished like i was recording
under stress okay so i'm really excited
for this album because i'm going to be
recording secluded somewhere
does your
father mother do they play a major role
in you calming down like you know i'm
hearing a lot of stress i'm hearing you
talk about like oh my god it was a crazy
time like do they play a role in getting
you to a place of of ease of comfort are
you still close are you guys talking a
lot
um we just got close i would say last
year
uh when you talk about week is it both
parents
really why why were you not close for a
while well growing up they would work a
lot i was always being babysat by the
people meaning people in my family
and then the opportunity
when it presented when it presented
itself i went away to college
went to san diego state then to usc
i've been independent for a really long
time
like i was that kid like in
third or fourth grade i had a key to my
house and i would walk home and had a
key to my house i would do my homework i
would clean the dishes i would make my
food
like
i've been independent for a really long
time and i've never that's something
that you're like angry about now that
you look back at it or are you
what's the feeling of that now
i think the feeling as a child was just
like i was always yearning for them okay
at the time
or were you okay with what was going on
like now at the time okay like i was
kind of like a sad little kid okay yeah
that's not i mean
by the way you're not saying anything
wrong it's crazy though
how how
it's the it's the same type of thing but
the opposite like i wanted that
so the freedom that you're talking about
your head or that you had i didn't have
i wanted that freedom really so you had
both parents well no my my dad was in
and out um on drugs off drugs in jail
out of jail but my mom was very strict
how old was like your parents uh i mean
when they had me uh-huh i don't know my
mom my mom passed away my i think at the
time my mom was what 35 36 when i was in
my high school years so it wasn't like i
had excited crazy super young parents
you know what i mean it was
the average age but my mom just didn't
want to make the same mistakes
so did you have was it that type of
thing was it yeah my mom had me when she
was 17.
makes sense yeah my dad was young too
they was just always hustling and
working was there respect
for the hustle at any point of
understanding like
why they're not around or well they
would always tell me we're a team in
order for us to win like you have to do
your part
so it's like my part was behaving being
responsible like i was like a little
woman
how did you not go down the wrong
the wrong path because i'm scared of my
parents
okay they are very like they're
enforcers
they were
i mean that's kind of impressive mm-hmm
because you could have easily
you could have easily done the wrong
thing like yeah the world is set up for
you to make the wrong decision it's so
easy to make the wrong decision so my
dad like if i wanted to go play outside
he would cut up articles about girls
getting abducted girls being sex
trafficked
kids making the wrong decisions and then
ending up somewhere they shouldn't be so
like he put me on game at a really young
age
put me on game
you're so bad
you're so bad
uh with this with this understanding of
life that you had at the young age i
mean i can only assume that you were
like crazy mature right
um you talking about them not being
around as you got older
i would assume that you voiced this to
them at some point in time when did you
have that conversation
um
i had this conversation
with my mom
um around that time i see girl came out
okay and then i had this conversation
with my dad last year on my birthday for
those who do not know icy girl
single very successful
single of yours um
why why did that act as a time for you
to say let me tell you how i feel
well my mom was just
amazed that i did what i said i was
going to do okay because she's asian so
like she's an asian she's mixed with a
it's filipino chinese asian filipino
chinese okay asian food yes i've seen
your mom
yes i know it's a lot going on there's a
lot going on in that pocket they're both
asian yes okay i get it
so she was amazed that you were able to
accomplish things that you've
accomplished yeah because a lot of
people i think it's like three percent
become musicians successfully
um i bought my own car had my own spot
and she just was like
proud of me and
she told me the reason why she raised me
so
the reason why she was so hard on me
because she
her life is just crazy i let she got to
tell it but um
she didn't want me going through what
she went through because she was on the
streets since she was like 14 years old
wow so she learned a lot through trial
and error and she just wanted to protect
me
in your conversation with her
how did your message come out did you
come in hot
no i'm very calm okay i kind of just
took it all in okay and she was just
like you're not gonna say nothing
but it was just a lot for me to receive
like i understood there was just some
parts i didn't understand and then she
broke it down
uh were there apologies were there lots
of apologies um
from them mm-hmm
they apologized for
my childhood
did it mean anything to you it meant a
lot to me mm-hmm now i'm speaking to you
as if i'm your therapist i'm not
i'm just asking questions but was there
ever a moment where you considered
therapy
yeah i did
you did therapy or you considered
therapy my mom put me in therapy in
sixth grade
and i tried a therapist in l.a um last
year it didn't work out so well why
didn't the one in la work out
it was a different type of therapy like
i just want to talk but she had me do
like a whole bunch of exercises and i'm
just like girl i just want to talk give
me an example of an exercise
um i think it was her
strategy was like cognitive
repairing cognitive decision i don't
know it's like rewiring how you deal
with your issues i'm hearing you talk
and you know from the way that you're
speaking about
meditation understanding the body
understanding self that's that you're
talking about therapy your vocabulary is
amazing are you well read
yes i was an avid reader when i was a
kid okay not as much now
still still mm-hmm i like your
vocabulary you spend a lot of words on
me and i'll be honest with you uh i
didn't i didn't understand what a couple
of them meant i just kept it flowing i
kept the conversation flowing because
you're trying to be funny right now no
just when i don't know what a word means
i think about it in my head
because cause you got me with a couple
of them so when you said cognitive i
just had to use it in context and i
figured it out uh but it means the way
you think i know what it can mean okay
i didn't i didn't know what it meant i
had no idea what that word meant so we
should actually put that underneath the
screen right now so the world can know
just because you guys didn't know what i
do know is that this is an amazing
conversation and it has to continue
let's take a break we'll be right back
with more heart to heart after this
[Music]
we are back guys we're back here on
heart to heart and i'm talking to
sweetie and uh we're having such a great
conversation i'm getting to know you
mm-hmm so much about you
what's going on can't waste it
okay well you don't eat
all right that's good
well perfect segue into my next question
yeah appetite
uh
you some would refer to you
as what's it called greedy there it is
some people would say
that
you're greedy uh
you have put
so much on display when it comes to your
love for food the concoctions that you
feel go together uh it's even landed you
a deal you know a deal in the food space
you had your own meal at mcdonald's um
before i get to the meal what what what
is going on with your system let's just
get into the to the meat and potatoes of
it why
why the mixture of such
random and crazy foods
it's random yeah you put like then you
put like cheetos and oodles and you do a
lot of a lot of crazy stuff this how i
do it
nobody showed me this but i'm telling
you okay so don't tell nobody all right
this is how i do it i feel like you know
to do these things
to to have the
understanding that you can do these
things at some point in time
uh life life
life was hard what when did you
when
when were you in the position where all
you had was ooze noodles and cheetos you
said i'm just gonna put them together
why do you like such random what is it
so
when my grandma would babysit me
i got nine aunties and uncles okay and
hella cousins
so there was always barely any groceries
in the house okay and you had to make it
do what it do in the kitchen okay so
like
i love food
so
because i was eating the same thing
almost every day like when she would
babysit us for like the summer time
we had to like just figure it out figure
it out figure it out and it's
has it ever has it ever put you in a
position where you felt like okay i
don't want nobody to see that i should
keep this a secret no i'm proud of my
food concoctions so you've never you've
never felt like i need to hide this why
it's heart-to-heart this is me and you
talking honestly uh-huh okay
you gotta have crazy gas
eating some of this stuff right let's
just let's just
let's just keep it 100 for a second okay
there's no way that your system is that
strong that you can take well yes that's
what i'm saying like let's just keep it
on so you're telling me you're telling
me that you've never been like i'm just
going to wait till i'm home by myself to
eat this i'm not going to do this around
comfort but that's where we going i'm
just asking there's no way that you can
do that like i've seen you eat some
crazy
i got stomachache still
it has to be
how did the mcdonald's offer come about
did they come to you
called you randomly and said oh my god
we have such a good idea
we've seen your love for our our product
and how you eat it we would love to
offer you
and it just
made sense well they called my agent um
shout out to mark cheatham love him
and
they were well aware that i would go
live
um
and a lot of my concoctions went viral
yes
yes that's how i'm aware of it as well
you do understand like that's the dope
thing about your brand when you talk
about
this young demographic you talk about
your fan base especially the women that
follow you you know you've created
and curated your own
ecosystem you know based off of social
media based off of engagement based off
of your impromptu moments right so they
follow you they love you uh-huh but i
feel like your business has evolved
because of your honesty the transparency
the authenticity that people have been
able to attach to you so it's really
dope that you got a food deal coming out
of you just being greedy
what that's what it is you're being a
greedy
you got rewarded for it it's dope as
hell i almost spit out my wine you don't
need to spit it out by the way no way
you're gonna waste that wine you're
greedy
okay
there's no there's no way that you're
gonna there's no way
there's no way that she's gonna waste
that wine uh right you might be the
funny you stop will you stop covering
your face like somebody throwing a
baseball at you you see she went no
cause my mouth i'd just be laughing
crazy when did you make the decision to
say this is it this is what i'm doing
with my life
this is what i'm doing i now have the
answers
i'm going to be
a musician i'm in the business of
entertainment when i was 15 15 years old
i told my dad what'd your dad say he
said rap for me
really
did you do it yeah
well yeah
my legs my lyrics were good but my
delivery wasn't good
and did he give you like
the dope support instantly like i love
it or was it like okay he said i hear
what you're saying but you got to get
more interesting
he took that yeah and every time he'd
have his homeboys over while they would
like
be playing dominoes he would make me
come out to the garage and rap for them
on the spot yes
i mean honestly that's a way to build up
crazy confidence because he was raised
up in hip-hop he was a break dancer he
was a bodyguard
um he was deep into like the hip-hop
scene yeah he got a he got like a lot of
attention for a minute when people found
out he was your dad mm-hmm a lot of a
lot of people was coming at your dad
crazy right
they used to wait outside for my dad
they're trying your dad no but like in
high school they was trying to be dead
too y'all like the senior girls would
like wait until i would get dropped off
at school and they'd be like
that's one thing me and your dad have in
common you know as uh
as
well just you know fathers first of all
and um you know men that are considered
to be
i don't know model-like uh you know it's
uh it's just something i relate to i
know what he was going through at the
time because i went through that phase
really when
hmm
i'm sorry would you say
when did i go through the phase
god i'm trying to think
there's waves there's different waves of
it there's different waves of it for
sure because right now mine's just you
know it's i'm probably coming down off
of it now but um yeah it was uh when did
it happen i don't want to talk to you
about this okay all right let me stop
you right here because we got to take a
break we got to pay some bills uh guys
don't go nowhere we got more heart to
heart when we come back after this
yes we're still here we're having a
heart-to-heart and i'm talking to
sweetie uh now we're into the music
business holy
you didn't just say you were going to do
it you actually did it mm-hmm you
actually did it right
you said yourself earlier you're part of
a very small percentage of people that
find success in this space oh my god you
found success in this space this dream
is no longer a dream it's reality right
it's reality look at your peers look at
the people that are now your peers that
you're alongside look at the other women
that you're able to stand next to and
that you're able to talk and discuss
music with holy
this is real right
you talked about the pressure that came
with it you talked about your ups and
downs well let's talk about where you
now want to be like you're in this space
i want to know what you want
from music what's the goal
well my goal is to become a media
company
so we're past viewing past
i feel like being a musician is the
foundation
and i've been able to create a strong
fan base from it but the next step up is
becoming a media company
that's pretty big
that's pretty big does business excite
you i love business you love business
more than the craft
um
i believe that
songs
are a form of service and i feel like
business is also a form of a form of
service so i like i like them both uh is
there a space or place where you
were able to grab the world of business
from like um this just come from just
being around
the
the entertainment world in itself or as
you've grown you've just seen things and
it made you say wow this is this is the
real one over here this is what i really
want to do
well in college i've always just been
intrigued with
doing my research
writing the essay creating the
presentation
on topics that i love and the topics
that i love currently is fashion
music sometimes acting i did grownish
philanthropy
products goods of service and because
i'm able to
create things that sell out
i love it go ahead
i love it but because i'm i'm able to
create merchandise and goods of services
that sell out
i've been inspired to
sell direct to consumer so that's why i
want to become a media company to house
all the brands and businesses that i
create so smart
when you talk about
uh you just checked off so many boxes
right so many things that you now have
access to that you're involved in you
mentioned acting for a second um
do you love it is there a want for more
my mom was an
aspiring actress okay so she was a
really hot video vixen when video vixens
had a great connotation to their name
she prides herself in it loves it so she
was simultaneously being a video vixen
along with being an aspiring actress
and while she would be getting ready for
her auditions i would be sitting on the
toilet of course with it close but i
would be like looking at her reading her
her lines reading the other character's
lines and she would be like acting and
rehearsing it with me and that's when i
fell in love with acting you were her
you were her
her set buddy her character yeah her
character and she would bring me to
auditions and she would have like the
girls in line like watch me while she
was like filming her tape
you you got to love that
you know and i heard what you said
earlier and i understand it you know i
definitely understand
your side of it when you're talking
about wow i just wish that they were
there more but you know they were
hustlers and then we hear the story
or stories that's attached to your
parents and hustling like your mom going
to an audition you're going with her she
goes in and people are sitting there
watching you i mean
stars stars are
there's no coincidence there's no
there's no accident
right like you are where you are you are
who you are
because that's what it's supposed to be
and when you look at your path
and trajectory of how you got to where
you get
you start to look at that it just starts
to make more sense like
look at the world of surroundings you
know what i mean like that's a dope
story
strangers these are strangers going in
for the same part that your mother's
going into but hey that hustle makes you
do whatever you can at the moment it all
makes sense watch my baby i'll be right
back out please well i wouldn't
necessarily say strangers like in the
acting and in
the video vixen world like she told me
you would regularly okay see people she
would audition with okay
most people ended up becoming your
friends yeah well her friends not your
friends no i like it though i like it
i'm here for it so that's where you got
the that's where you got the acting bug
uh-huh growing us you do it
you love it
um
was that like something that just came
your way did you audition for it was
there a call out to you how did that
come about
so they asked me if i wanted the part
because it fit
my lifestyle it was a musician
however they said it was just for one
episode but i did so well they called me
back for two years yeah
mm-hmm oh miss humble over here what
anybody see this over here
oh miss humble over here i did so well
they called me back for two i mean jesus
christ jesus christ you know what on
that note how about we take a break so
we can calm this one's head down jesus
christ we'll be back with more can i get
a refill yes you can we got more heart
to heart after this we'll be right back
so let me know if they're coming back
for more oh jesus christ
jesus christ
[Music]
we are back here on heart to heart and
i'm still here what so wheatie and yeah
she's eating um you know no shocker
she's been eating during the whole break
um and then and it won't stop it won't
stop i haven't touched any of this
none of it
i'm sorry i just wanted people to know
yeah
what is it that's great here oh
mother
oh
is it bad guys
guys is it bad get up
jesus low blow
that is a low blow well played
well played you see what she did
anybody see what she did there
tried to make it look like she was
helping me when in fact she just put me
down didn't she
hurt my confidence
we just took a break so we can't take
another break can we i gotta just eat
that
uh
let's get into the world of astrology
every time we take a break you keep
telling me stop acting like a cancer
right this goes more into the world of
understanding
self uh people
reading people expectations um is this
like a real thing for you
like in one way are you like one of
those people that live by it like what
are you what's your sign i'm a cancer
you are cancer when's your birthday july
2nd i'm july 6th i know
you don't think that's something you
should set
i did my research
so you don't think i did
something you would have known
nobody wanted to tell me that we had a
birthday four days apart
joey
you did didn't you
yeah i'm sorry joe you did four days
apart holy
uh that's actually big now i get it
i understand it now
i get the the the go get i get the
the hustle i get like the
want for more now
i'd say that may be like our thing
that's a cancer thing
what are our flaws it's cancers
well i heard no i don't know you heard
like what no because i'm in
unconventional cancer what does that
mean
like these don't apply to me
[Laughter]
okay give me give me
what you've heard
like allegedly we're emotional
are you
i'm not emotional
i'm a thug
why is that the biggest laugh hold on
no no i was serious
wait a second
why is that the biggest laugh that you
had since you've been here
grandma thug you wanna see my arms
okay
all right well i'll cut that out
that was too hard of a laugh
emotional
i'm not emotional though uh-huh i don't
think i'm emotional
i mean i get a little upset sometimes
i i cry a little bit but i don't i'm not
like every day
like twice a week
a good cry is good just to let it out
okay that's about it
and i'm like i don't like people to say
means
all right what else are we emotional
we're big lovers that's true we're very
empathetic
if i didn't know what that meant
let's just define it you know we can
sense people's emotions got it yeah i do
that all the time yeah i can sense that
mm-hmm and that's pretty much us we got
big hearts
i got a big my name is
uh no no we love heart we love heart um
you know one thing that
i definitely can say that
we are and i know this from other
cancers too we want to see other people
happy
even if it drains a lot energy
ah
now it's clicking
you feel like you give a lot of yourself
um
i can relate
i can relate i don't want nothing in
return i don't care if you say thank you
i can relate i guess just like i want to
see you
shine and do you feel like at times
that's not received i don't feel like
it's reciprocated
oh
to reciprocation okay to reciprocation
so the only reason why i asked you the
question
about in front of people versus
not
because that's the only thing that you
actually can control is who do i want to
be aware
of who i decide to love and when i
decide to love
and is the public thing my cup of tea
or is it not you are absolutely right
and you know what
when i was in my self-reflection so i
don't check social media like that no
more if you live for the internet if you
live for social media you'll die by
social media okay so that's why i
stopped checking for stuff
i'm gonna break it down and i'm gonna
get
i'm gonna get much more simple
mm-hmm i'm gonna dumb it down you just
gave a great
detailed version of double down for me
this i'm gonna dumb it down come on
dummies
not for dummies but just uh just watch
this just look at the simplicity of the
books okay you know
if you
don't cut your phone on
you go about your day
that day is gonna be so great
because you're making a decision
to just have a good day
right
go to a market you'll get coffee
you go sit down and eat drink with your
friends
chill watch tv whatever it is you're not
bothered by anything right
because the thing that presents the
problems that make you feel like so much
else
is happening and so much more is going
on
you've made a decision to put away
you control that thing
nothing can get to you if you don't want
it to get to you
mm-hmm so
social media in the world of it
it only presents problems
to those that allow the problems to
infiltrate their bubble
so if i choose to take this and put it
down
mm-hmm
there is no problem
i have no idea what's going on because
i've chose to not invest
in that thing mm-hmm so when you say
yeah i don't really deal with it anymore
it's not that difficult
of a thing
well it takes 21 days to break a habit
and ask somebody who checked her phone
every day
it was
it was i caught myself a lot just
not conscious about me going to
instagram or twitter to a social media
network
like
i wouldn't even be thinking i would end
up there like that's how much my body
was programmed
so i'm trying to download you know just
new habits i forgot who i was talking to
on here and um i told him i was just
saying like there's a there's a timer
it's a screen time timer right
so if you really want to control it
go to settings
and you go to the apps whether it's
instagram
twitter or favorite whatever it is
and you have an amount of time that you
a lot for yourself to be on it so if
it's something that you really want to
hammer down and bunker down on and not
do put a timer on it i like that give it
an hour i don't have your time and it's
fun and it's whatever but that's it
has no effect over
your reality your real your creativity
of now mm-hmm you're able to do so much
more
i know a little bit about a little
a little bit about a little
that's my one piece of information that
i'll give you not advice information
see that
it's good look at you look at that i
know that's right i know that's right
no that's right geez we're gonna take
one more break it's getting really deep
here on heart to heart uh when we come
back guess what this won't be here she
would have probably devoured it over the
course of that break we got more heart
to heart when we get back after this
[Music]
we are back guys this is heart to heart
and i'm still here with sweetie i like
to say
sweetie you know why i say it like that
simply because we're having such a great
conversation and we're comfortable more
comfortable you get the more engaged you
get and we talked about everything let's
go from the top we talked about i mean
not only where you were from we talked
about uh
where you went uh after realizing where
you went we talked about your family
your upbringing um and the reason for
why you are the way you are as we
approach the end of this show i got to
now talk to you about
the now right
and then now this new version of you
well it's present we're in a new year
and it seems as if
there will be a new you
this new you i wouldn't say new i would
say elevated elevated correction yes an
elevated version of you um what are the
priorities
for you in this year
the priorities is establishing my media
company
creating the infrastructure for it and
recording this album
priorities definitely acting
acting absolutely absolutely got to
throw one more in there cause you were
so good remember you reminded me of that
you were so good they brought you back
again
very humble you are look at you come on
memory
[Laughter]
i will say
um
i very much am a fan
of my fellow
entertainers uh male female it doesn't
matter i love to see people succeed and
and talking to you today i just like the
fact that you're not afraid to talk
you're not afraid to be yourself
and and being yourself i told you
earlier on it presents the opportunity
for so much more right um
partnerships brands evolvement um more
importantly
your growth is happening
right in front of your fans eyes they're
seeing you become
uh
a superstar right and the superstar it's
not going to die down it's only going to
get bigger it's only going to become
more so i love the fact that you're
checking yourself you're trying to gain
more control and it's going to pay off
you know there's value in that and
there's a great example in that not just
for myself
um for other entertainers as well you
know i think checking in and making sure
that our mentor is strong is what we
need to prioritize and i love that
you're doing that i want to congratulate
you on all your success that you've had
and i want to say that you know your
dark days well they could have been the
darkest so let's focus on the ones that
seem to be uh full of nothing but light
bright sunshine success ahead okay
you're dope
cheers wait hold on okay hold on i got
something to say too
but i'm about my gray hair again
is it about my gray hair again so the
reason why i was laughing so much is
i've been a fan for a really long time
like i've watched all your stand-up
comedies
i watch all your netflix
projects
specials um i watched true story i binge
watched it while i was getting my nails
done
and
like some of the expressions you make
are some of the expressions
you make um
on your tv shows your standups
and
it's been such a pleasure this is dope i
told you it's gonna be a great
conversation i know it is but it's just
crazy because from seeing you on screen
to seeing you in real life it's like
you're the same person but i'm taller
yeah i'm taller
right i think that's the one big
takeaway because i'm taller so
and knowing that i think that's the
biggest thing for people out there to
realize that in person i'm a lot taller
absolutely yeah that's what you were
doing no lies yeah so cheers to just
understanding my height in real life
cheers this is much better
maybe we get a close-up on my shoulders
maybe just if we push in
just to kind of yeah just kind of make
that thing make sense uh guys this is
heart to heart you can't have a
heart-to-heart without good people and
what we found today is that cancers are
some of the best i know that's right i
know that's right
july 2nd july 6. thank you so much for
coming on the show girl you are
absolutely amazing stunning i hope you
guys walked away with a better
definition than what you thought you had
this person is so much more
dying
and that's a rat yes
i really believe there's nothing that we
can do it's season two me and my
celebrity friends are back an asian
person can affect western culture you're
56 56 is only young when you die at 56.
[Music]
you